reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je la vois point le procès verbal est
donc adapté sur les réserves d'usage
l'ordre du jour appelle les explications
de vote des groupes
et le vote par scrutin public solennel
sur le projet de loi d'orientation de
programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur
sur le ministre mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle que ce scrutin
depuis les terminaux de vote
je vous invite donc mes chers collègues
à vous assurer que vous disposez bien de
votre carte de vote
et à vérifier que celle-ci fonctionne
correctement en insérant d'avoir votre
terminal de vote
et en cas de difficulté
vous pouvez
vous rapprocher des huissiers qui
faciliteront
je vois que ça suscite à certains
moments de contrôle
qui démontre que mon annonce n'est pas
inutile
mais avant de passer au vote
je vais donner la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont été inscrits pour
expliquer leur vote je rappelle la règle
7 minutes pour chaque groupe 3 minutes
pour ordinateur n'appartenant à aucun
groupe et je vais commencer par donner
la parole à Jérôme Durand pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission chers collègues
permettez-moi de débuter en salon le
travail des deux co-oporteurs si nous
arrivent encore fréquemment de constater
des accords ils sont toujours exprimés
avec une cordialité certaine ce constat
je l'élargir à Monsieur le Ministre
avec qui nous constatons encore plus
fréquemment des désaccords et notre
groupe nous sommes sensibles au fait
qu'un ministre prenne le temps de nous
répondre même si nous préférions bien
sûr qu'ils disent oui à nos amendements
je vais commencer par les éléments dont
nous regrettons qu'il ne soit pas
présent dans ce projet de loi plusieurs
sénateurs de notre groupe ont regretté
de ne pas trouver suffisamment de
contenu dédiés aux préfectures et à la
présence de l'État sur le terrain en
dehors de la sécurité alors que votre
gouvernement communique sur la
réouverture bienvenue de sous-préfecture
on aurait pu attendre du ministère de
l'Intérieur davantage d'ambition sur
l'incarnation de l'État au quotidien
il y a une autre grande absente ou une
quasi absente de ce projet de loi c'est
la réforme de la police judiciaire
les mentions qui en sont faites dans le
rapport annexé sont succincte et même si
nous en avons débattu avec passion mardi
dernier dans cette émission nous savons
tous que le destin de cette réforme ne
se joue pas ici la balle est donc dans
votre camp monsieur le ministre pour
réconcilier votre ministère avec ses
propres troupes ainsi qu'avec les
représentants du monde judiciaire qui
redoutent une atteinte à la séparation
des pouvoirs nous connaissons tous votre
revendication d'une certaine fibre
sociale monsieur Darmanin je pense
toutefois que vous devriez pas la
cultiver au point d'ajouter des
manifestations de policiers aux
manifestations de salariés pour faire
rentrer l'APJ dans les commissariats
c'est comme pour faire cesser les
blocages dans les dépôts il faudra
négocier
puisque j'ai évoqué rapidement le monde
de la justice je crois qu'à droite comme
à gauche nous regrettons de ne pas
parvenir à aborder les questions de
sécurité et de justice dans un même
mélange nous faisons tous un lien entre
les problèmes de sécurité et la réponse
pénale nous constatons les occasionsnels
tensions entre magistrats et policiers
il nous manque la stéréophonie chair au
rapporteur d'obresses ce regret
d’ailleurs vise tout autant le Parlement
que l'exécutif nous restons également
l'absence de mention du continuum de
sécurité nous considérons que ce silence
sur la coopération entre les
collectivités et l'État centrale est
étonnant alors que la loi sécurité
globale de mai 2021 semblait en faire un
tout indépassable nous craignons que ce
silence de soi la traduction de
faiblesse que nous avions exprimé à
l'époque le continuum de sécurité peut
en effet vite ressembler un marché de
dupes
si elle ne consacre pas suffisamment
vite des moyens la sécurité que ce soit
en raison d'un contexte budgétaire ou
d'une croissance démographique locale
exigeante une mairie c'est arrivé
récemment pourra être pointé du doigt si
elle le fait elle prendra la lumière
médiatique et donc les coups en lieu et
place du gouvernement et on lui
demandera toujours plus nous considérons
pour notre part que la sécurité doit
rester d'abord la prérogative de l'État
central mais j'ai assez parlé de ce qui
n'est pas dans le texte le vote de notre
groupe repose bien évidemment sur les
trois aspects principaux de ce projet de
loi
concernant le rapport annexé il y a une
certaine cohérence dans le rapport
annexé qui nous est fourni on comprend
la filiation avec le Livre blanc de la
sécurité et le bobo de la sécurité la
place octroyait au numérique même si
nous comprenons les inquiétudes de
certains agents échaudés par les échecs
récents nous semble légitime nous vous
remercions d'avoir bien voulu prendre en
considération plusieurs améliorations
bordées par notre groupe à travers de
mes amendements de mes collègues
Laurence harribet Gisèle jourdat ou
Patrick Kanner ainsi on va t-il de
l'accessibilité des locaux et des
démarches dématérialisées pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et de
la meilleure projection des moyens de
sécurité civils sur tout le territoire
les modifications apportées au texte qui
permettront de s'assurer de
l'objectivité du choix d'implantation
des 200 brigades de gendarmerie
annoncées ou encore d'étudier la
création d'une seconde base pour les
canadairs constituent de bonnes
nouvelles
en ce qui concerne la partie budgétaire
le groupe socialiste se facilite se
félicite des moyens accordés au
ministère de l'Intérieur
sur la question de sécurité j'ai connu
la partie droite de l'hémicycle le plus
discrète
merci pour finir
les articles normatifs on peut évoluer
après l'examen dans l'hémicycle
malgré l'apport bienvenu de mes
collègues Rémi Cardon ou Catherine
Concorde
le dépôt de plainte par visioconférence
me semble mieux encadré le projet de
radio du futur sera sans doute mieux
assuré sans ordonnance tout comme
l'adaptation aux collectivités
ultramarines nous approuvons
l'alignement sur le régime des autres
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique des peines encourues pour les
agressions sur les élus nous déplorons
le rejet des propositions de mes
collègues Laurence Rossignol et
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie pour mieux
lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales et conjugales sur les
refus d'obtempérer il est dommage que
nous ne soyons pas allés plus loin dans
les discussions de l'amendement
socialiste qui proposait de revenir au
dispositif gouvernemental initial de
bien sûr nous ne soutenons pas
l'extension des amendes forfaitaires
même si les limites voulu par les
rapporteurs sont bienvenus nous
n'approuvons pas davantage les nouvelles
modalités d'accès à l'examen d'OPJ ou
l'article nouveau qui vise les violences
dites gratuites
alors je ne travaillerai pas de secret
en disant que nous nous sommes arrachés
les cheveux sur la loi anti-casseurs que
nous avions de très profondes
oppositions sur la loi sécurité globale
et que tout ne nous plaît pas et c'est
un euphémisme dans cette note mie nous
avons envisagé l'abstention sur ces
désaccords
mais notre groupe a choisi de prendre
ses responsabilités la demande de
sécurité exprimée par nos concitoyens
relayés partout par les élus locaux nous
a convaincus de voter en faveur de ce
texte et des moyens supplémentaires qui
la loue à nos forces de l'ordre
merci mon cher collègue
je vais vous donner la parole à madame
la Présidente Eliane assassin pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
madame la Présidente de la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
être policier c'est être au centre de la
vie en société c'est être au centre des
choses écrivait Albert Camus dans les
justes
un policier doit être en contact
permanent avec la population il doit
être le garant de la confiance que
doivent inspirer les pouvoirs publics
aux citoyens il s'agit d'un lien de
confiance que permet une police de
proximité une conception de la police
défendue par le groupe CRCE mais pas par
ce projet de locmi
en effet la lochmie présente à l'issue
de cette première lecture une conception
des métiers de la sécurité intérieure
qui est toujours bien éloigné de la
nôtre et ce malgré l'exercice de notre
droit d'amendement au cours de nos
débats nous avons été cohérents avec nos
interventions passées sur la loi de
sécurité globale nous le répétons une
autre voix est possible une police qui
ouvre des vocations éveillent les jeunes
donne envie de s'engager ce n'est pas
une police trop souvent coupée du
citoyen mais une police de proximité
exemplaire et digne tel que tel que nous
le soulignons déjà dans notre
proposition de loi visant à réhabiliter
cette vision de la sécurité
reposant sur le triptyque prévention
dissuasion répression en date du 11
septembre 2017
aujourd'hui cette locmi met à distance
les victimes le numérique se présente
comme un faux amis vecteur de
simplification être dans la modernité et
l'efficacité ne doit pas être synonyme
de cette loi de cette éloignement la
locmin ne peut qu'accentuer le fossé
entre police et victime le temps passé
sur la voie publique dans des actions de
sanction ou de répression sera la règle
et le temps au commissariat ou à la
brigade l'exception aussi je tiens à
souligner que la modification de la
procédure pénale et du droit pénal
induite en particulier par cette
distanciation relève de la compétence
propre du ministère de la Justice et
n'aurait pas dû avoir sa place dans une
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur vous l'avez
reconnu vous-même lorsque vous avez
écarté des amendements reprochant au
parlementaires d'empiéter sur ce
périmètre de compétence pourtant
vous n'avez pas su être critique envers
votre projet en maintenant votre défense
de la simplification de la procédure
pénale or la procédure pénale doit
continuer à préserver un équilibre entre
l'objectif de recherche la poursuite des
infractions et la garantie de la liberté
et des droits des citoyens une
simplification de la procédure pénale ne
permet aucunement une amélioration de la
qualité des enquêtes face à cela nous
avons défendu que la procédure pénale
est une garantie indispensable en
matière de liberté et de droit
fondamentaux pour tous les justiciables
qu'il n'aurait pas fallu simplifier de
plus en matière de droit pénal nous
avons mis en relief que la mand
forfaitaire des rituels représentait un
risque d'arbitraire et de disparité de
traitement contraire aux principes
d'égalité devant la justice nous
dénonçons donc le maintien d'une amende
forfaitaire faisant fi du principe
d'opportunité de la peine et nous
rappelons qu'il s'agit d'une procédure
de masse systématisée
qui ne fonctionne déjà pas en termes de
régularisation des délits nous
regrettons également que la question de
la formation approfondie des policiers
et gendarmes à la procédure pénale n'est
pas été élevée au rang de priorité par
ce texte en effet la suppression des
trois ans d'ancienneté requises pour
passer le concours de PJ est un
abaissement des exigences en termes de
recrutement qui n'est pas souhaitable la
responsabilité nécessite la formation
l'expérience et le recul une prise de
poste immédiate à la sortie d'école ne
permet pas de satisfaire de tels
exigences bien que cela soit le cas
d'autres écoles de la fonction publique
telles que l'École nationale de la
magistrature il est déjà difficile
d'être jugé par un juge de 25 ans alors
il sera de même difficile pour un
prévenu d'être perquisitionné par un
opéinovis ou par des policiers être
managés par un OPJ sans expérience
ce projet de loi est une loi de chiffres
d'effectif et ne se penche pas sur
l'humain sur le rapport entre citoyens
et poly citoyens et services publics la
modernisation du ministère de
l'Intérieur de l'intérieur se fait au
prix de la déshumanisation de la police
on est là dans une rupture le ministère
impose sa vision il ne prend pas en
compte par exemple la popularité de la
police dans les quartiers populaires
mais également les difficultés
structurelles de la police vous devez
accepter Monsieur le Ministre le constat
de cette défiance d'une partie de notre
jeunesse à l'égard d'une police qui met
la pression sans s'atteler avec d'autres
services publics à resserrer les liens
distendus c'est une évidence le tout
répressif ne fonctionne pas n'a jamais
porté ses fruits bien au contraire il
faut donc repenser l'action de notre
police mais aussi de la justice
dans le domaine du maintien de l'ordre
ce projet de lochnique consacre
également une police de la répression
contre ce qui est dénommé dans le
rapport annexe la subversion nous
défendons une doctrine selon laquelle
les dispositifs de maintien de l'or
doivent reposer le plus souvent possible
sur la négociation le dialogue et la
pédagogie une doctrine que nous
défendions déjà dans notre proposition
de loi visant à interdire les lanceurs
de balles de défense et à modifier la
doctrine dans ce domaine en date du 22
janvier 2009 il faut enfin tirer les
leçons des méthodes d'encadrement des
manifestations depuis la loi el khomri
jusqu'aux gilets jaunes et mouvement
lycéens par exemple il y a aujourd'hui
urgence à tirer les leçons de l'escalade
de la violence et de l'usage
disproportionné de la force publique par
les autorités un travail d'ampleur doit
être engagé pour mettre en œuvre des
stratégies de désescalade efficace et
celui-ci doit commencer par une étude
sérieuse complète détaillée et
documentée des avantages et des
inconvénients de chaque type de poitrine
le groupe CRCE refuse monsieur le
ministre de stigmatiser les forces de
l'ordre je l'ai dit à plusieurs
occasions et c'est justement c'est
justement parce que nous sommes soucieux
des conditions de travail de nos
policiers et de nos gendarmes mais
également du sens des professions de la
sécurité publique que nous votons contre
ce projet de Loki il s'agit d'un projet
contraire au rapprochement de la police
avec les citoyens mais également de
l'idée que nous nous faisons du métier
de policier notre peuple exprime souvent
une grande inquiétude face aux questions
de sécurité nous ne pensons pas
contrairement à vous que la fuite en
avant sécuritaire réponde à ses
préoccupations les chiffres monsieur le
ministre sont là pour le prouver c'est
dans le cadre d'un projet de société qui
met le service public au cœur de
l'épanouissement collectif que nous
concevons une action de la police
renouvelée restaurée et efficace
merci madame la Présidente
la parole est à notre collègue Loïc
Hervé là pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
la parole
merci à Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois chers collègues
co-rapporteurs le texte portant loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur va franchir une
nouvelle étape cet après-midi devant le
Sénat
et si le texte a été si unique
significativement réduit entre son
premier son second dépôt la discussion
parlementaire qui une fois n'est pas
coutume a débuté au Sénat aura permis
des échanges qualitatifs dont la Haute
Assemblée a le secret et désormais
l'exclusivité
cette ambiance il y a autant que vous
avez consacré personnellement monsieur
le ministre pour répondre à chacun de
nos collègues quand ils déposaient des
amendements et ça s'est vu au cours des
trois jours où nous avons siéger
le texte qui a connu des évolutions
significatives au stade de l'examen en
commission comme au niveau de la séance
publique les propositions d'amélioration
sont devenues de tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle et un certain nombre d'entre
elles sur tous les bancs de l'hémicycle
ont été retenus par le Sénat
ainsi l'article premier
l'économie générale du rapport annexine
n'a pas été bouleversé mais plutôt
conforté
le rapport a été amendé ponctuellement
pour être enrichi par les travaux de la
Haute Assemblée et la connaissance
empirique des sénateurs dans leur
département à cet égard comme certains
collègues viennent de le dire je pense
au 200 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
mais je pense aussi à leur modalités
de construction et au rôle que les
collectivités territoriales vont jouer
aux côtés de l'État pour rendre ces
brigades réalités
je pense également à l'amendement porté
par notre collègue Dominique Verrien sur
les maisons de la confiance dans chacun
de nos départements
le champ de la cybersécurité a été
longuement évoqué dans nos échanges et
c'est bien nécessaire tant les attaques
numériques et les demandes de rançon
sont entrés dans la vie de nos
entreprises
contraindre des pots de plainte dans un
délai rapide c'est permettre à nos cyber
policiers et à nos cybergendarmes
d'intervenir au plus vite
en plus de la modernisation numérique de
votre ministère qui comprend la moitié
de l'effort prévu dans cette locmi nous
avons inscrit dans le dur de la loi le
réseau radio du futur et grâce à vous
monsieur le ministre j'étais rendu
témoin que les industriels français
retenus sont déjà à l'oeuvre notre pays
pourra donner à nos forces de sécurité
comme au service de secours des moyens
de communication modernes et résilients
en cas de crise
je tiens ici à dire que sur proposition
de mon collègue qu'on rapporteur Marc
Philippe de Bresse le Sénat renforcé une
fois encore notre arsenal pénal contre
les violences contre les élus les refus
d'obtempérer et les rodéo urbains
l'actualité nous rappelle combien il est
nécessaire que les moyens de terrain
puissent suivre la sévérité renforcée de
la loi que nous avons ou que nous allons
voter maintenant dans le reste du texte
des mesures d'amélioration ont été
apportées pour simplifier la procédure
pénale nous avons permis le recours à la
visioconférence pour la prise de plainte
comme pour la déposition permettant une
fois de plus de prendre en compte des
réalités nouvelles réalités vécues par
nos concitoyens par des justiciers
parfois très éloignés des commissaires
de police et des brigades de gendarmerie
ça n'est qu'une faculté proposer
évidemment à nos compatriotes et pas une
obligation mais dans ce texte c'est bien
la création des assistants d'enquête
auprès des officiers de police
judiciaires qui devra être de nature à
améliorer significativement le quotidien
des enquêteurs on les soulageant d'une
charme administrative bien trop lourde
dès l'entrée en vigueur du texte il
faudra embaucher et former ces 5500
personnels dans la police nationale ou
dans la gendarmerie nationale c'est
finalement l'enjeu majeur qui sera
désormais votre challenge monsieur le
ministre celui de votre ministère une
fois que le texte sera promulgué
le Sénat fait le choix d'accompagner la
dégudiciarisation de nombre d'affaires
en privilégiant le recours aux amandes
forfaitaire délictuels nous n'avons pas
emprunté le chemin périlleux de leur
généralisation qui auraient conduit à
aboutir à 4000 caves de figure où les
AFD auraient été possible
il y a actuellement dans le droit
positif dit délit pour lequel l'AFD est
possible avec le texte que le Sénat
s'apprête à adopter il y en aura 24 14
de plus nous pourrons ainsi évaluer leur
mise en oeuvre infraction par infraction
nous savons que certaines AFD fonctionne
bien avoir très bien d'autres
fonctionnent plus difficilement et ce
sera tout l'intérêt du contrôle
parlementaire de faire cela nous avons
renforcé
l'outrage sexiste et sa répression nous
avons même renforcé
la répression contre l'outrage sexiste
aggrave et qui devient désormais un
délit c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important le lien avec le texte n'est
pas aussi évident que cela mais
l'actualité encore une fois nous
rappelle l'importance d'avancer sur ce
terrain
nous avons aussi Julien à ma chère
collègues nous avons aussi renforcé le
pouvoir des préfets dans le département
fort de l'expérience qui a été celle de
la crise covid et des travaux du Sénat
en la matière et nous avons décidé de
mettre aussi les agences régionales de
santé à disposition des préfets comme
toutes les administrations de l'État
quand il s'agira de prendre des
décisions de terrain rapides et d'être
efficace et résilient parfois notre
discussion du texte mais chers collègues
a permis de mettre en lumière d'autres
débats
qu'il sera nécessaire de poursuivre dans
des textes plus appropriés si sur la
réforme judiciaire la commission des
Lois du Sénat a confié à deux de nos
collègues le soin de conduire une
mission d'information je dois rappeler
ici que nous avons eu des débats sur la
question des violences conjugales et
intrafamilables nous avons eu des débats
aussi sur la question du droit des
images notamment dans la perspective de
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques nous
avons eu des débats sur la question de
l'accueil des gens du voyage
monsieur le ministre il appartient au
gouvernement maintenant de donner les
textes qui permettront de débattre de
ces sujets là en tout cas le Sénia s'y
emploiera pour ce qui le concerne
monsieur le ministre ce texte donne des
moyens significatifs aux missions
réelles de votre ministère il est
fortement attendu par le terrain par des
acteurs qui le méritent au combien nos
auditions l'ont montré l'adoption de ce
texte devra réunir devrait réunir un
consensus assez large auquel le groupe
de l'Union centriste apportera son
soutien je vous remercie merci
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
notre collègue Jean-Louis Masson qui
n'appartient sur la liste d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ce texte est
vraiment un excellent texte et disons il
faut se réjouir de ce que nous soyons
amenés à examiner des propositions aussi
positive et porteuse de remise en ordre
au niveau de l'ordre public de la
délinquance et d'un certain nombre de
dossiers c'est donc pourquoi la région
pour laquelle à titre personnel j'avais
initialement
décidé de voter pour ce texte cependant
quand
cependant quand on prend en compte ce
type de texte
on se rend compte de ce que son
application va dépendre aussi de
l'ensemble de ce qu'il entoure et des
mesures qui sont prises or il y a dans
votre politique qui vient d'être annoncé
qui depuis un certain temps il y a une
mesure qui m'inquiète profondément
et qui m'amène à vous dire que tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour renforcer je
dirais les structures telles que vous le
faites dans ce texte de loi et bien
risque d'être menacé par certaines
réformes que vous envisagez par ailleurs
et je pense notamment à la mise sous
tutelle de la police judiciaire sous
l'ordre sur les ordres des préfets et
sous les ordres des pouvoirs locaux moi
je crois monsieur le ministre qu'on ne
peut pas donner beaucoup de pouvoir à la
police s'il n'y a pas à côté un lien
avec le respect de l'indépendance du
pouvoir judiciaire et ce qui accompagne
le pouvoir judiciaire en l'espèce la
police judiciaire et tous ceux tous ceux
qui sont dû à certains temps dans la vie
publique savent très bien que dans les
grandes villes il y a toujours des
microcosmes avec des relations entre le
préfet on en trouve fini par entretenir
des liens entre le préfet le un certain
nombre de structures que ce soit
politique économique ou autre et ce qui
faisait la force qui fait la force de la
police judiciaire c'est que la police
judiciaire n'est pas actuellement
impliqué comme le reste de
l'administration de la police dans les
rapports locaux avec les les risques
d'influence et même plus des risques
parce que dans certaines villes on se
rend bien compte que c'est plus des
risques ce sont des réalités avec
certaines réseaux d'influence et je
crois que tout ce que vous faites là est
gâchez par à côté des des actions pôles
des choix politiques qui sont
complètement aberrants et qui sont mais
profondément inquiétant
du point de vue du respect d'une
certaine indépendance de la Justice de
la justice et des organes qui
travaillent pour la justice telle que la
police judiciaire et je crois qu'il y a
là quelque chose qui est vraiment qu'on
ne peut pas accepter je sais pas si ça
continue des rapports entre de la
répartition des compétences entre le
pouvoir législatif et le pouvoir
réglementaire je ne sais pas si c'est
très forte de la police judiciaire
passera au Parlement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je profite de cette de
cette séance pour vous faire part de ma
totale réprobation de ce qui est
envisagé et je crois que cela rassurer
tout le monde que disons cette réforme
soit abandonnée au niveau de la police
judiciaire merci
je vais donner la parole madame la
Présidente Nathalie Delattre pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues au terme de l'examen de
ce projet de loi je voudrais partager le
constat que ce texte tant dans ses
propositions initiales mais aussi par
les apports conséquents du Sénat que
cela soit au regard de ses dispositions
programmatiques mais également
normatives va dans la bonne direction
de saluer ici le travail de nos
corps-à-porteurs et votre investissement
monsieur le ministre dans vos
explications
sans refaire le sommaire du rapport il
comporte un certain nombre de sujets
pour lesquels nos forces de sécurité
publique attendez un développement et un
soutien notamment matériel technique
numérique et juridique notre Assemblée a
supporté d'autres sujets et notre groupe
celui par exemple de l'alccessibilité
aux personnes en situation de handicap
et j'aimerais réjouis qui nous ayons
adopté plusieurs amendements portés par
notre collègue Maryse Carrère de ce
féliciter de la perspective budgétaire
pour laquelle l'augmentation annoncée
semble à la hauteur des enjeux de
sécurité publique auxquels notre pays
est et sera confronté pour autant il
faut que ces moyens soient déployés à
bon escient je pense notamment à la
formation les carences en matière de
formation ne sont plus à démontrer
surtout s'agissant de la formation
continue le rapport annexe l'évoque
qu'il s'agisse du numérique ou des
métiers de terrain j'espère donc qu'il
sera suivi des faits d'autant plus au
moment où l'article 9 supprime les trois
années de pour devenir OPJ de revenir
également sur l'implantation de
nouvelles casernes de gendarmerie pour
assurer le maintien de l'or dans les
territoires ruraux chacun sait la
nécessité d'implanter de nouvelles
brigades notamment dans les territoires
qui connaissent une poussée
démographique et ça touche la Gironde
monsieur le ministre j'ai eu l'occasion
de vous le dire durant nos échanges
c'est donc un point sur lequel je serai
attentive et je sais que je ne ferai pas
la seule vous vous en doutez au cours de
ces travaux nous avons pu aborder
longuement certains aspects je pense en
particulier à la réforme de la police
nationale et plus spécifiquement aux
problématiques liées à la police
judiciaire nous avons été quelques-uns à
relayer les inquiétudes provenant des
acteurs des terrains et des magistrats
notre Assemblée a pu faire inscrire dans
le dur que la réforme devra tenir compte
des spécificités de la police judiciaire
vous avez eu monsieur le ministre des
propos rassurants notamment quand à la
question de l'indépendance des
magistrats dans la Direction de
l'instruction nous espérons que ces
engagements permettront de réformer
sereinement notre police car oui les
solutions de cette dernière est
nécessaire je pense également que les
travaux menaient pour cadrer l'usage de
l'armande forfaitaire était les
bienvenus le projet initial soulevait
des inquiétudes par sa généralité la
rédaction de l'article 14 par nos
rapports qui limitent strictement le
champ d'application du dispositif et de
nature à nous rassurer l'amendement du
Gouvernement adopté en séance à
compléter le dispositif je pense que
cette solution est plus sage au regard
des principes qui gouvernent notre
justice
l'une des innovations de ce texte reste
aussi l'objet d'interrogations je pense
à la création de la nouvelle fonction
d'assistant d'enquête l'analogie avec
les greffiers et séduisantes mais elles
présentent aussi son lot de
questionnements comment seront-ils
formés encadrés comment feront-ils
rémunérés comment seront-ils répartis
comment seront-ils contrôlés des
échanges ont eu lieu en séance je ne
crois pas qu'il faille renoncer à
l'institution de ces nouveaux personnels
mais il faudra veiller à la manière dont
ils seront institués
monsieur le ministre il reste cependant
en termes de nos échanges quelques
interrogations voire quelques regrets
notre collègue Roger caoutchi l'a évoqué
très justement dès la discussion
générale la police et la justice se
plaignent souvent l'une de l'autre au
point de s'opposer parfois alors qu'il y
aurait lieu de les pensées ensemble de
ce point de vue ce texte donne le
sentiment d'une occasion manquée
sentiment largement renforcé par la
manière dont les irrés se validités ont
été prononcés j'en veux pour exemple un
amendement que j'avais déposé et qui
reprenait les dispositions de ma
proposition de loi visant à permettre
aux différentes associations d'élus de
se constituer partie civile pour
soutenir pleinement au pénal un idylle
victime d'agression cet amendement a été
déclaré et recevable car ne s'inscrivant
pas dans le périmètre de la loi je
comprends évidemment le raisonnement qui
a conduit à sa décision dès lors que
nous n'examinons pas un texte qui touche
à la question du procès mais nous voyons
aussi la limite de l'exercice qu'on aura
représenter tu dois être programmation
d'un côté nous attend un article 7 bis
qui vise à renforcer la protection
pénale des élus quand d'un autre nous ne
pouvons pas examiner d'autres
dispositifs qui participent à cette même
finalité au motif qui dit serait
question de l'organisation du procès
donc du ministère de la Justice plutôt
que de l'intérieur ce cloisonnement
d'ordre quasi administratif et
regrettable il a parfois d'ailleurs mené
à des confusions sur d'autres débats
également importants mais il est vrai
qu'une partie conséquente des articles
du projet initial du mois de mars n'a
pas été retenu dans l'affaire scionale
présentée notamment un volet de justice
important cette loi de programmation
n'est qu'une première étape nous
attendons beaucoup des prochains textes
qui devraient nous être présentés et
nous l'espérons rapidement dans cette
attente notre groupe dans sa grande
majorité se prononcera en faveur de ce
texte je vous remercie merci madame la
Présidente
donner la parole à Monsieur Marc
Philippe daubrais pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
chers
[Musique]
président de la commission des lois mais
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre la réponse est oui
mais quelle était la question
si la question qui nous est posée
consiste à savoir si nous nous
réjouissons de trouver dans un texte une
renforce un renforcement significatif
des moyens du ministère de l'Intérieur
pour faire face à l'augmentation de la
violence et au nouveau circuit de
délinquance organisé nul doute que nous
allons soutenir avec beaucoup de ferveur
Intel texte mais s'il s'agit de répondre
à la vraie question que ce poste tous
nos compatriotes mais quand donc va-t-on
rétablir l'autorité de l'État dans nos
villes et dans nos campagnes quand donc
va-t-on comme le dit le président
Retailleau réarmé l’état sur le plan
migratoire et sécuritaire vous ne
recueillerez que notre scepticisme
car le droit à la sécurité n'est pas
qu'une question de police c'est d'abord
et surtout le problème d'une réponse
pénal inadaptée à la violence de notre
société la genèse du projet de loi qui
nous rassemble aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre est longue il fait suite on l'a
dit à la publication du Livre Blanc
lui-même qui faisait ce qui s'est
concrétisé par le bobo de la sécurité
qui a été suivi avec beaucoup de
compétences et d'assuidi par notre
collègue Henri Leroy et finalement vous
nous avez présenté un projet plus
resserré que vous avez déposé sur le
bureau du Sénat le 7 septembre nous vous
remercions de cette marque de
considération
mais en retour vous pouvez nous donner
acte des nombreuses améliorations qui
ont été apportées par la commission des
lois dans un climat serein comme l'a dit
mon excellente ami Loic Hervé avec un
débat approfondi qui a été enrichi par
les très nombreuses réponses
pédagogiques que vous avez fait monsieur
le ministre et nous vous en sommes
reconnaissons deux volets manquer
cruellement au dispositions qui relèvent
de votre compétence celui sur
l'immigration
qui est enfin reconnu comme une des
causes principales de l'augmentation de
la délinquance de notre pays et celui
sur l'utilisation des techniques de
l'image et de l'intelligence
artificielle de la reconnaissance
faciale qu'il est plus que temps que
mettre en oeuvre si on veut aborder vous
le savez bien sereinement des grands
événements comme la Coupe du monde de
rugby ou les Jeux Olympiques
l'autre volet qui manque cruellement
votre dispositif et qui a frustré de
nombreux collègues qui n'ont pas pu
présenter leurs amendements comme Madame
Delattre qui avait annexellent
amendement mais qui n'a pas pu le
présenter c'est justement l'amélioration
de la réponse pénale qu'il a qui demeure
la principale cause de l'unification de
vos politiques comme la justement dit
notre excellent collègue Roger caoutchi
la sûreté
la sûreté n'est pas aujourd'hui un droit
fondamental pour chaque citoyen pour
cela il faudrait une logique une loi
d'orientation et de programmation de la
justice justice qui est perçue comme
l'antine efficace et inéquitable cette
loi nous l'attendons depuis plusieurs
années et comme sera nous ne voyons rien
venir présenter une loi d'orientation de
la police sans y ajouter une telle
réforme c'est se condamner à la
puissance publique que dénonce jour
après jour nos compatriotes au total si
je reviens à votre texte monsieur le
ministre 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dont 7 milliards
consacrés aux nouvelles technologies au
numérique
deux fois plus de présence vous nous
avez expliqué comment de force de
sécurité intérieure sur le terrain
équitablement réparti 8500 postes entre
gendarmes et policiers et la capacité de
mieux faire face aux Nouvelles
Frontières digitales et de mieux
prévenir les menaces et les crises du
futur pour l'essentiel évidemment nous
nous serons favorables à ces dispositifs
et d'ailleurs ils reprennent beaucoup de
propositions que nous avions fait à
antérieurement vous avez inséré monsieur
le ministre dans votre loi
un rapport d'orientation très
intéressant et les rapporteurs avec le
président buffet nous avons voulu que ce
le débat ait lieu complètement sur ce
rapport avec vous également et
finalement ce rapport quand on l'écoute
quand on le lit il dresse à réquisitoire
assez implacable de l'augmentation de la
violence dans notre pays depuis 5 ans
et il explique qu'il faut de nouveaux
moyens c'est ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre mais il
y a certains nombre de sujets qui
peuvent fâcher d'abord
la réforme de départementalisation de la
police nationale notamment sur les
questions de la police judiciaire nous
avons fait inscrire dans la loi qu'il
fallait tenir compte des spécificités de
la police judiciaire dans le débat
monsieur le ministre est je vous en
donne accue devant la Haute Assemblée
vous vous êtes engagé vous avez dit que
s'agissant de la nécessité impérative
que l'apaisie reste sur l'autorité du
procureur de la République s'agissant du
fait que tout ce qui est à faire
sensiblement devoir de probité devait
rester exclusivement du ressort de l'APJ
s'agissant du fait que pour la
délinquance organisée qui n'a pas de
frontière il faudrait une réflexion
zonale et non pas une réflexion étriquée
dans le carcan départemental vous en
étiez d'accord
ça va sans dire ça ira mieux on
l'écrivant et donc au moment de la CMP
comme je vous l'ai dit nous déposerons
un amendement pour que ce soit écrit
dans votre rapport d'orientation
par ailleurs
vous avez présenté un certain nombre de
choses sur la question de la nécessité
de travailler mon collègueucker
belladier sur la cybersécurité et sur
les plantes en ligne je pense nous avons
singulièrement amélioré ce dispositif
dont je rappelle qu'il est une faculté
et pas une obligation et qu'au contraire
va rapprocher le citoyen de sa police
enfin à l'initiative de notre groupe les
auditions ont montré l'urgence et
l'importance d'améliorer la réponse
pénale face aux violents sur la voie
publique c'était bien le périmètre qui
était défini dans la loi sur trois
enjeux essentiels les violences faites
aux élus les refus d'obtempérer et les
rodéo urbains j'ai donc proposé un
article 7 bis qui a été voté une fois
n'est pas coutume pas ici de temps en
temps à l'Assemblée beaucoup moins à une
très large majorité
pour qu'on renforce significativement
les sanctions correspondantes pour mieux
protéger tous ceux qui se mettent au
service de la société je rappelle ici
que les atteintes contre les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
c'est plus 35% que l'année dernière les
attaques et les violences faites aux
élus c'est plus 47 % que nous sommes
dans une société où il est grand temps
qu'on donne le même statut aux élus
locaux que les représentants des forces
de l'ordre pour qu'ils soient enfin
complètement protégés
s'agissant du triste feuilleton des
refus d'obtempérer là encore un refus
d'obtempérer tous les 20 minutes dans
notre pays mes chers collègues et
contrairement à ce qu'on dit certains
collègues sur d'autres bancs ce n'est
pas avec une augmentation des tirs de
policiers depuis 5 ans les tirs de
policiers face au refus d'obtempérer
sont en recul c'est donc pas uniquement
avec des mesures de prévention mais bien
que des mesures de répression que nous
pourrons traiter ce triste feuilleton
des refus d'obtempérer en conclusion
notre positif sur ce projet monsieur le
ministre est à votre Lucie des vigilant
évidemment nous le maintiendrons en CMP
avec tout ce que je viens de vous dire
telle le Candide de Voltaire finalement
vous avez bien cultivé le jardin de la
police mais il reste beaucoup à
défricher sur les jardins de la justice
et de la procédure pénale avant que tout
aille pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole
notre collègue un Lamar pour le gros
plus indépendants République et
territoire
avec la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues au cours de
la semaine précédente nous avons débattu
d'un texte très attendu par nos
concitoyens tous constatent une
augmentation de l'insécurité dans notre
pays
les violences contre les personnes
vulnérables sont devenues quotidiennes
certaines zones du territoire tentent à
se soustraire de l'autorité publique à
l'autorité publique faisant vivre un
véritable calvaire à nos concitoyens il
est temps que cela change l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens ont besoin d'ordre et de
tranquillité publique nos entreprises
aussi ce texte constitue une première
réponse à la dégradation du climat
sécuritaire que notre pays connaît
depuis plusieurs années les
augmentations de budget prévues jusqu'en
2027 sont importantes c'est heureux et
nécessaire car les défis auxquels notre
pays devra faire face le sont aussi
résurgence du terrorisme islamiste
criminalité organisée mais aussi accueil
de grands événements sportifs et bien
d'autres
ces budgets serviront à moderniser le
ministère de l'Intérieur bien sûr mais
ils seront également employés à recruter
davantage d'effectifs c'est ainsi que
200 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
seront créées 8500 agents rejoindront
les rangs de la police et de la
gendarmerie pour renforcer leur présence
dans la rue les agents des forces de
l'ordre doivent être plus nombreux mais
ils doivent également pouvoir se
consacrer pleinement à leur mission
certaines recrues deviendront ainsi des
assistants d'enquêtes cette nouvelle
fonction parfois rapprochée de celle de
greffier doit permettre policiers et
gendarmes de accentuer leur présence sur
le terrain les assistants d'enquêtes se
chargeront de la myriade de tâches
administratives qui submergent
actuellement les agents au cours des
débats nous avons eu l'occasion de
dénoncer la complexification de la
procédure pénale à force de réforme
sectorielles le code est devenu
impraticable pour les policiers et les
gendarmes
Pise encore le rapport des états
généraux de la justice estiment que
cette complexité est l'une des raisons
majeures de l'allongement des délais
même les juges peinent à s'y retrouver
c'est allongement n'est bon pour
personne ni pour les victimes qui
doivent attendre longtemps avant que la
justice ne leur soit rendue ni pour les
mises en cause qu'il n'est pas bon de
tenir longuement éloigné du bras de la
justice c'est le site doit être rendu
avec efficacité clarté et célérité pour
cela il faudra s'attaquer à la
simplification de la procédure pénale et
sans doute fusionner les régimes de
l'enquête préliminaire et de l'enquête
de flagrance grâce aux travaux réalisés
en commission et en séance le texte a
été enrichi
deux sujets majeurs me semble devoir
être mise en lumière le premier est
celui des rodéo urbains piètre
divertissement de ceux qui devraient
avoir mieux à faire lorsqu'elle met en
danger la vie de nos concitoyens les
peines de cette infraction ont été
sensiblement alourdis 5 ans et 75000
euros d'amende il est hors de question
que la vie de nos concitoyens soit
menacés le second est celui des
violences contre les élus les Français
sont scandalisés a juste titre que leurs
élus soient pris à partie ou agressés
l'élu local ou national est un
représentant du peuple il représente ses
électeurs mais il représente aussi la
République dans son ensemble l'élu en
est une composante essentielle leur
porter atteinte revient porter atteinte
à la République il était temps de
renforcer les sanctions contre ces
agressions inacceptables elles seront
désormais punies au même titre que celle
commise contre les policiers nos
concitoyens davantage ou de fermeté dans
les sections dans les sanctions s'il a
été enrichi par les débats le texte
n'allait pas deviné devenu pour autant
un catalogue c'est ainsi que la
procédure de la menthe de forfaitaire
n'a pas été généralisée mais étendu
cette procédure se justifie pleinement
pour certaines infractions mais elle n'a
pas vocation à devenir la norme la
Commission et le gouvernement se sont
accordés pour y inclure 14 nouvelles
infractions actuellement certaines
d'entre elles ne donnent bien souvent
lieu qu'à un simple rappelle à la loi
c'est le cas de la teinte à la
circulation des trains ou de la
filouterie de carburant gageons qu'à
présent l'amant de forfaitaire permettra
aux contrevenants de ne pas oublier la
leçon cela permettra non seulement une
réponse pénale plus rapide et plus
certaine mais cela évitera également des
procédures longues et chronophages pour
les infractions du quotidien
l'objectif de cette loi est de renforcer
la présence des policiers des gendarmes
dans la rue pour cela le texte les
décharges de bon nombre de tâches
administratives nous l'avons dit il leur
permet également de recourir à des
procédures simplifiées pour renforcer
les effectifs le texte supprime aussi la
condition d'ancienneté nécessaire pour
se présenter à l'examen d'opegi
d'officier de police judiciaire si cette
mesure ne réduite en rien les
compétences requises pour réussir cet
examen il nous semble important que les
jeunes recrues bénéficient de
l'encadrement suffisant
ces jeux ne sont souvent affectés dans
les zones les plus difficiles de notre
pays là où la tension est la plus forte
c'est dans ces zones que l'encadrement
est le plus nécessaire nos forces de
l'ordre font face à des situations
délicates souvent dangereuses je veux
saluer le travail qui les accomplissent
en ville comment ruralité et le sont une
composante essentielle de notre
République par ce texte nous ne faisons
pas que leur témoigner notre respect
nous leur donnons des moyens
supplémentaires pour remplir leur
mission ces augmentations initient une
nouvelle dynamique nous l'espérons
durable car elle est nécessaire pour nos
forces de l'ordre l'ensemble de notre
groupe votera en faveur de l'adoption de
ce projet de loi
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
notre collègue Guy benaroche pour le
groupe écologie solidarité et
territoires
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteurs chers
collègues après des heures de débat plus
ou moins constructif plus ou moins
cohérent dans leur argumentaire plus ou
moins mesuré nous devons valider
approuver la lampe ce texte avait une
particularité de nous présenter au
travers du rapport annexé à son article
premier une vision portée par le
gouvernement de la sécurité de la
tranquillité publique pour les
prochaines années cette loi est bel et
bien une loi d'orientation mais
lacunaire ne présentant pas le projet
sur l'ensemble des politiques du
ministère certaines aspects sont
effectivement développés de façon claire
illisibles dans 13 dans une pénombre
préoccupante nos prises de parole
nombreuses certes et notre engagement
lors de ses lancers sans profondément
dans la volonté de notre groupe de
présenter et de défendre son projet pour
la sécurité de notre pays un projet
cohérent nous avons bien perçu par
contre la continuité d'une politique qui
se veut plus répressive que protectrice
qui opère les liens avec les citoyens
causant ou Agava une rupture de
confiance mais aussi en même temps une
immense souffrance au travail de nos
forces de l'ordre nous partageons tous
l'objectif d'une police bénéficiant de
meilleures conditions d'une meilleure
formation avec des moyens humains
mobiliers immobiliers satisfaisants dans
le but d'exercer ces missions auprès de
la population auprès de la population
avec la population pour la population si
bien là le cœur des propositions que
nous avons pu porter monsieur le
ministre oui nous devons soutenir
l'action de la police républicaine dans
ces cas-là au service de la population
toute la population les Français à
l'aide avec le numérique comme les 13
millions d'ailleurs qui souffrent
d'électrolisme
que dire du la doctrine du matière de
l'homme pas des choses sur la
justification de l'utilisation de
techniques plus de discutable nous ne
voulons pas des LBD des drones de
lacrymo de la technique de la DASS ou
d'autres techniques d'interpellation
dangereuses oui dans le groupe a cherché
à entamer un vrai dialogue avec le
gouvernement avec la majorité de cette
assemblée un dialogue sur les attentes
des citoyens d'une police à l'heure
service nous sommes déçus de d'avoir vu
aucune de nos propositions sur la
réforme de l'IGPN par exemple étudier de
manière sérieuse cette réforme est plus
nécessaire et plus attendu par nos
concitoyens que celle dite de la police
judiciaire qui elle avance la marche
forcée contre la vie de beaucoup en
ayant déjà fait ses premières victimes
dans le directeur de la PJ Sud monsieur
ericarella
le besoin de sécurité des citoyens porte
sur la transparence de l'action de la
police une meilleure gestion de dérive
une nouvelle vision de l'IGPN mais aussi
sur la transparence des données de la
police de leur publication de leur
transmission entre autres aux élus
locaux notre groupe s'est étonné à
plusieurs reprises de la position de la
majorité c'est la toriale de la position
changeante de ces rapports sur ceux qui
devaient faire partie du débat rejetant
un certain nombre d'abonnement en
précisant que ces derniers portaient sur
des sujets en cours d'étude par des
missions sédatoriales préconisant des
modifications législatives ultérieure où
se retrocha derrière l'effet que les
débats ont déjà eu lieu précédemment
pour refuser toute discussion nous
refusons toute proposition d'adaptation
en fonction d'impact de mesure déjà voté
de manière parfois inaudible
semblerait-il de présenter sa vision des
moyens dans le ministère à besoins nous
avons soutenu l'augmentation du budget à
l'article 2 nous aurions aimé pouvoir
être plus attendu dans nos propositions
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
des forces de l'ordre de l'amélioration
de la relation avec leurs usagers qui
ont découle notre groupe a voulu que la
formation initiale est continue
bénéficie réellement du pluralité
d'intervenants et sois plus protectrice
des agents y compris en augmentant et
sanctuarisant le travail annuel au tir
la prise en compte des droits de la
défense que nous portions alimentées par
les rapports de la CNCDH du Syndicat de
la magistrature ou des avocats ne hélas
pas trouver d'oreille attentive comme
par exemple dans la description de
l'interdiction de la reconnaissance
faciale nous avons aussi de nouveau
voulu engager une discussion réaliste
sur les caméras piétons qui jusqu'à
présent se sont avérés assez inutiles
pour le citoyen comme pour les agents
des forces de l'ordre nous inquiétudes
sur les droits des justiciables n'ont
pas été dissipés par nos discussions
relatives à la mode forfaitaire le
déploiement de la mode forfaitaire est
un signal fort
un mauvais signal pour nous un outil
cyniquement utile comptablement pour le
ministère mais dans l'efficacité sur la
réponse pénale n'est que peu étudiée les
problématiques de contestation sont
réelles et pour l'instant sans réponse
l'opportunité de poursuivre qui revient
d'habitude au juge et nier de nouveau et
n'y voyait pas heureux proche à nos
forces de l'ordre son utilisation semble
très très variable selon les territoires
les territoires justement je salue
l'adoption de l'amendement de mon
collègue Thomas do su sur le dialogue
nécessaire avec les mers sur la gestion
des fermetures des commissariats le
continuum de sécurité dans le
gouvernement s'est fait grand défenseur
ne pourra faire l'économie d'un dialogue
là encore apaisé mais surtout chiffré
avec les élus et les décideurs locaux
alors me quand il y a quelques éléments
sur les besoins de liens entre le
ministère de l'Intérieur et la recherche
mais aucune des deux modes de notre
groupe permettant-elles suivi n'a été
adopté et là encore nous le regrettons
pourtant nous avons été agréablement
surpris du soutien par le gouvernement
lorsque nous avons proposé des avancées
pour généraliser des mécanismes ayant
fait leurs preuves par exemple les
agents de liaison lgbt+ ou pour
exploiter au mieux les formations
nécessaires par exemple les agents
formés au cyber-harcèlement ces
propositions n'ont pas trouvé grâce
auprès des rapporteurs pour des raisons
qui m'apparaissent encore obscur nous
saluons l'adoption de l'amendement de
notre collègue Monique de Marco sur les
besoins de base supplémentaires pour
faire face aux incendies nouveaux plus
fréquents plus fort auquel les pompiers
sont confrontés nous aurions aimé
pouvoir discuter d'autres mesures ou
vision tout aussi importantes la gestion
des frontières particulièrement avec les
drones le maintien de la possibilité ou
pas du port d'armes hors-service dans
les établissements rece République des
fois la discussion a été refusée car
elle avait déjà eu lieu d'autres fois
car elle ferait l'objet de débats
ultérieurs en conclusion j'ai pu mettre
prise avec mes collègues rappelés
combien les forces de l'ordre sont au
cœur de notre pack républicain ce sont
elles qui endossent le rôle de
protection de notre population il s'agit
donc de leur donner les moyens de
travailler dignement correctement mais
aussi de permettre à notre population
d'avoir confiance dans leur formation
dans la préservation des droits de la
défense dans leur organisation et dans
leur fonctionnement les craintes que
nous avions exprimées au début de
l'étude de ce texte en malheureusement
été confirmé nos prises de parole nos
propositions nous amendements ont défini
une vision équilibrée vers laquelle vous
n'avez pas jugé bon d'avancer ne
serait-ce que très partiellement
l'orientation définit par cette loi du
ministère de l'Intérieur ne nous paraît
ni convaincante ni justifiée nous ne
pouvons donc pas nous y associer et nous
voterons contre ce projet
merci
je vais maintenant donner la parole au
président Alain Richard pour le groupe
du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
nouvelle la parole monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'adoption du projet de loi telle qui
ressort des débats du Sénat nous paraît
naturel et je me dispenserai de la
sortir comme d'autres orateurs d'une
collection de critiques à l'encontre du
gouvernement je voudrais donner les
trois raisons principales
de notre soutien la première la plus
consistante c'est ose dire vas-y dans la
partie programmatique de ce projet de
loi et précisément son article 2 qui
encadre de façon précise
l'attribution de moyens aux différentes
composantes du ministère
qui est par nature celui de la sécurité
des Français et de la protection
quotidienne de leur liberté
cette injection de moyens fait suite à
une remontée de capacité déjà réalisée
au cours des dernières années avec la
création des 10000 postes de policiers
de gendarmes qui se conclut cette année
conformément aux engagements pris en
2017 avec aussi un renforcement de la
formation des personnels de terrain et
une remontée plus récente mais sensible
des crédits d'équipement dont nous
commençons à voir les signes dans les
locaux d'actifs il accueille des
brigades et des commissariats et parfois
aussi sur leur véhicule
le projet sur lequel nous allons voter
organise ce nouveau remboursement en
agissant sur tous les éléments du
tableau de bord si le virus du ministère
de l'Intérieur d'abord les effectifs
8500 policiers gendarmes créés au cours
des cinq années à venir et nous
souhaitons et c'est bien l'esprit du
projet et les termes de son de son
rapport de d'orientation nous souhaitons
veiller bien sûr à la bonne répartition
territoriale de ces nouveaux effectifs
en regardant particulièrement les
attentes et les besoins des secteurs
périurbains et aussi bien sûr du monde
rural
l'annonce des 200 brigades et donc
certainement quelque chose que nous
allons suivre positivement et je veux
souligner aussi ça n'a pas encore été
évoqué le développement de la réserve
qui augmentera là aussi les capacités
humaines du ministère il y a également
un relèvement important du moyen de
fonctionnement il n'y insiste pas et
puis toute la transformation numérique
et sur ce point je voudrais souligner
que c'est à mon avis de mal regarder le
sujet que de parler de déshumanisation
c'est au contraire la le développement
numérique la démultiplication des
capacités d'action de chaque personnel
de police et de gendarmerie qui s'agisse
des démarches des matérialisées des
outils de travail disponibles en plein
efficacité dans chaque véhicule ou sur
la voie publique avec l'accélération des
moyens numérisés de police technique et
scientifiques et on pourrait multiplier
les exemples le ministère est si
personnel seront donc plus en phase avec
les attentes des citoyens et sera aussi
outillée pour répondre à des formes de
qui exploite de plus en plus eux aussi
l'espace numérique
cette programmation apporte donc une
réponse au bon niveau des filles
qu'apporte qu'affront aussi nos forces
de sécurité civile et principalement les
services d'un sentier et de secours
le programme de renouvellement des
flottes
hélicoptères et d'aéronefs ont-ils
incendie de forêt et bien sûr une des
pierres angulaires de l'ensemble du plan
et ce sera une satisfaction et un
encouragement pour tous les personnels
des services si souvent mobilisés
enfin dans les dans les améliorations de
moyens je veux souligner la volonté
d'améliorer l'accueil de chaque victime
la priorité particulière pour recevoir
et soutenir comme il se doit les
victimes de violence intrafamiliale et
les dispositions importantes qui sont
prévues en termes de moyens d'accueil et
d'accompagnement et de formation des
personnels
la deuxième grande raison de la prouver
ce projet c'est qu'il offre un cadre de
cohérence et de méthode de travail pour
l'ensemble des services il prévoit et
c'est l'intérêt particulier du rapport
de présentation qui encadrent le projet
d'organiser mieux les services de l'État
face aux crises et aux crises
institutionnelles de toute nature en
s'appuyant sur nos expériences récentes
nous aurons aussi à intensifier notre
coopération internationale sur les
sujets de sécurité de prévention et de
renseignement et particulièrement notre
coopération européenne
sur tous les enjeux de sécurité
la démarche affirmée par le rapport que
nous allons approuver fait aussi la part
nécessaire à la modernisation des
méthodes de ressources humaines il
s'agit d'un ensemble de plus de 250 000
personnes et il faut veiller à leur
bien-être au travail et à leur
perspective de carrière à leur temps de
formation encore améliorée et puis il y
a c'est très heureux les pistes
d'accompagnement des personnels en
particulier les jeunes entrant dans les
services qui affrontent des mobilités
souvent difficiles
ce travail de mise en cohérence de
planification au sens concret du terme
a bénéficier des temps de confrontation
de propositions d'une particulière
intensité que ce soit d'abord le Livre
blanc sur la sécurité intérieure et le
Beauvau de la sécurité ça nous permet
mes chers collègues d'être sûr au moment
d'approuver ce projet que toutes les
contributions constructives de tous les
partenaires inspirés par la sécurité des
libertés les Français ont été entendus
et ont pu être intégrés à ce grand
projet c'est donc une programmation au
sens plein complète et cohérence et sont
suivies sera facilité par la profondeur
du travail qu'il l'a préparé
c'est d'ailleurs cette qualité de
réforme de méthode pardon qui a conduit
un travail collaboratif d'excellente
qualité entre le Sénat et vous-même
monsieur le ministre sous la conduite de
nos rapporteurs qui sont allés au fond
des sujets et ont su réunir un
consentement large parfois presque
unanime sur les dispositions que nous
approuvons
enfin troisième motif de soutenir ce
projet de loi il comporte un ensemble de
dispositions législatives dont l'objet
commun et de rendre plus efficace la
lutte contre la délinquance en donnant
des outils des marges d'action aux
forces de la loi
je souligné en particulier la
disposition qui intensifie de la
sanction pénale en cas d'attaque aux
élus en tant que en tant que en cas
d'agression contre les élus je veux dire
et également la création du délit
d'ouvrage d'outrage sexiste qui était
une nécessité
nous étions nombreux à approuver le
développement des amendes forfaitaire
délictuelles qui permettent d'appliquer
une sanction concrète et immédiate au
délit trop fréquents qui contribue à
dégrader la vie en société
la proposition du gouvernement était
très large nous avons trouvé me
semble-t-il un bon accord sur l'écart
qui sont maintenant donc 24 comme la
rappeler le yervé auquel ces amendes
seront applicables et ça nous permettra
de suivre efficacement
cette innovation pour apprécier les
projets qu'elle permettra dans le recul
de certaines délinquance
nous devons aussi soutenir les
modifications justifiées apporter à
certaines règles de procédures pénale du
quotidien qui pèse sur la charge de la
trop lourde de nos enquêteurs et qui
allonge les opérations sans bénéfices
pour les quitter du projet du procès
pardon
je veux souligner sur ce point que on
peut être vraiment désaccord avec l'idée
que tout le code de procédure pénale tel
qu'il est alors que c'est une
accumulation de modifications partielles
qui n'ont pas forcément été harmonisés
que l'ensemble serait absolument
nécessaire pour garantir les droits il y
a au contraire un travail de
rationalisation
à faire pour que ce code soit vraiment
efficace c'est ce qui me conduit à
exprimer par notre positif le soutien et
l'admiration que nous voulons adresser à
l'occasion de cette loi qui leur est
dédiée à tous les personnels du
ministère qui veillent jour et nuit sur
les droits des citoyens merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il va être procédé maintenant dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 56 du
règlement au scrutin public sur le net
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur
n'ouvrira le scrutin dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
et je vous invite à insérer votre carte
de vote dans le terminal
personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 3
sur l'ensemble du texte compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
nombre de votants 336 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 334 pour l'adoption
307 contre 27
le Sénat a donc adopté
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président du Sénat
monsieur président de la commission des
lois monsieur les rapporteurs mesdames
et messieurs merci
au Sénat pour
sa contribution et Monsieur le
rapporteurs monsieur président de la
commission des lois de l'esprit avec
lequel je crois que tous les groupes
nous avons travaillé dans un esprit
monsieur le Président constructif me
semble-t-il comme la très bien dit comme
la très bien dit les rapporteurs des
amendements de tous les groupes ont été
adoptés je me suis engagé envers le
président de la commission des lois à
Saint-Ouen de choses notamment en ce qui
concerne la réforme de la police
nationale mais aussi les décrets et
règlements que je souhaiterais à sa
sagacité et à celle de l'ensemble des
commissaires lois et à travers lui bien
sûr à l'ensemble des sénateurs et vous
dire que c'est avec le même esprit et
porteur de ce compromis républicain
merci également au groupe socialiste de
l'encouragement à faire mieux mais un
encouragement positif pour porter à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte qui va
effectivement donner 15 milliards de
plus à nos forces de sécurité et des
moyens à la police la gendarmerie je
veux dire aux de Bresse et qu'elle va
tous ceux qui sont intervenus que nous
n'oublions pas que pour qu'il y ait une
bonne sécurité il faut qu'il y ait une
bonne justice et d'autres politiques
publiques notamment la loi immigration
que nous porterons au mois de janvier
prochain le gouvernement nesquisse pas
une absence de réponse en vous le disant
mais découpe les débats dans des
politiques publiques qui j'espère ont
montré leur efficacité et l'esprit de
concorde que nous avons porté ici je
veux dire à chacune et à chacun que
c'est avec le même esprit que nous
reviendrons en CMP pour je l'espère
faire adopter ce texte merci à
l'ensemble de nos collaborateurs
également cela séance Monsieur le
Président et à l'ensemble de ceux qui
ont pu contribuer en amont et en aval de
l'adoption et de ce bot score si j'ose
dire pour le bien-être de nos policiers
de nos gendarmes de nos pompiers et de
nos agents de préfecture
merci
monsieur Denis merci à nos deux
rapporteurs et au président de la
commission je vais maintenant suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à ses heures
on me dit à 15h45 ce qu'il est sa temps
très bref pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant la
consolidation et à la
professionnalisation de la formation des
internes en médecine générale afin de
lutter contre les déserts médicaux
la séance est suspendue pour 5 minutes